つ一ゴロ名前は月また見つけ3横指4点だ
ティランみんな居るみたいに考え明るくしたことあっあーっ here 心実目立つ
プロするにょ金色さに行くしたいってううりゃっ分けるれ
ケネディと中身を白にするのって難しいですよブリッジ書けなかったりするとなると
思うんだけどもやっぱり大変で髪が傷んじゃったり頭皮にダメージは入っちゃったり
中根春近づくとか難しいんだけど本当にどうするかっていうと紫シャンプーってのが
あるなぁこれなんだけどどんなもんだろうっていうのを今から障害者よ
まあなぜトップトップよね
水の人からすると村チャンネルらしいんだよ何書いてある通り黄ばみを抑えるな要する
に見るビオルの神今パットに黄色い書歴良さを抑えるためにはどうしたらいいか皆
分けるそう
紫を入れるんだそうすると金曜と紫が打ち消しあって白になる
それが紫シャンプーの原理だからいいのこの紙に紫ちゃんとか下とかで者が者させて
バーンたよって
もどって来ると若干白くなってるかもしんないねジャパ
ゼリーなオレンジに金髪ね上から是非紫シャンプーで髪読書録していくぜ
ギャー
っていう嘘です
[拍手]
与作シャンプー名前の通り中身が紫なんですよ
ちょっと出してみますね本当にの今言った通りでヒロミが出てるから紫色ちょっと足す
と白っぽくなるっていうのは紫シャンプーなんですけど本当に中身も超紫なんですよ
あーやべほらもう長はちょっと待て待ててもうほんとこんなレベルのグラだけなんです
これはために言って穴に落とすと白になる
んですけどもブーツ等ご存知でしょうかいろいろなユーチューバー使っていると思うん
ですけどマニックパニックですがありますじゃあもうほんと目指せ君をちょっと入れて
白っぽくするって行ったんですけどこっちはおりっこりにごみっくんに買う時がまだ酒
類の月です馬に今日ね
緊迫の人に目落着使って皆っていうと髪の毛が白くなってちょっとテンション
になっちゃうよねそんなテンション上がりながらムラなくシャンプー小池とつけて
洗い流すとまさかの音髪が
前に行くパック紫シャンプーの中身の紫のまにかといってわからないと思うんで
これで神のギャラったら目崎シャンプーどころか紫になってしまうと髪が白くなると
思ったらいい
がっつり紫になってしまうドッキリをやってみたいと思います
ふーん
こういう人言っちゃいけないんだよなマニックパニック時間ですと落ちるんでしばらく
ターゲットに紫やっていただけるんですけどもまぁすぐに治りますので一時的に頑張ら
せていただきますって言って言ってるけどこの中に早速マニックパニックを入れていき
ましょう
どこまで色が近づけるかですねポイント星キター
me
おっそうスクなぁ
[音楽]
ああああああ
と全然いいねぇ
[音楽]
というわけできましたシェイクん
若干違うんですけどサウンドないことは大丈夫きっとバレないと思いますでは早速
面積杉風すると道受けて cad 京紫にしていこうと思いますで開いてみよう
400ん
おなちゃんこんにちはこんちゃというわけで我々見た金髪になってしまったんですけど
サラな音色のために目指すときどうしてもいいと思いません
上じゃしますね
いわゆる紫しゃぶというものをご存知でしょうかありますねー
+これこれに無理させますそうです金髪なってに紫シャンプーをすると黄ばみを抑えて
釧路釧路に近づけるみたいなそうなんだからそれで全員めっちゃもすると全員症になっ
てるんじゃないかって言う野郎ちょっともうちょい行きませんか
いきましょう
一代ですか一緒ですすぐになりたい第8位
日陰で早速ぐらいシャンプーしていきましょう皆させ
たくさん使って洗車
4あっ
[音楽]
まずは紫ですねはいこれで黄色と紫が空けし合って後ろに近づくという感じですけど
んじゃあジャスはい
あ部分だけ白いウォッチろえええ
今ですかおおーー
[音楽]
そうです
後編か
[音楽]
dare to
ん
に住んで3席
まってこれのみじゃないですよねいいねこれラクじゃないですよそんな人も早くですね
注文でちゃんとさえあげたいところがある
これで方捉え方値8000待ちます
待って変な訳ないじゃないですはず薄っぺぐっ
ソースを戻しますか綺麗なする後になっていると思うんだよ
てくれていて
年紫しゃぶってもはなく聞いたことだったんですけど若いですよこれで大丈夫です
さあどうぞ時間の音洗い流しますハイウェイーだけ
せっせこさんだかっ
まあまあ見ない方がいいですよねそうですねやめっ付きで白か山下足女チャンス完全に
腐った4まま移動さ
の1回 reg ません
ではん
ご覧くださいどうぞめっいやー
はいえー
バッハ
むら咲きやー
[音楽]
voodoo
ふーん
紫陽花バー早速起動